[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport sur TV 78 l'émission et
surtout pas manquer si vous avez fait du
sport votre passion ici on parle bien
sûr et de sport local mais aussi de nos
sportifs yvelinois qui comme d'habitude
font la une de l'actualité la recette du
succès de cette émission mythique lancée
par Michael elmidoron le salut bien sûr
et des analyses techniques des
décryptages le tout dans une bonne
humeur et pour m'accompagner nos
chroniqueurs qui sont avec nous sur ce
plateau encore plus motivés que les
joueurs de La Rochelle face au Leinster
présentation en musique on commence à
droite c'est le capitaine de cette
équipe il se remet en selle rien que
pour vous c'est un pistard de niveau
international il a été champion du monde
de cyclisme sur piste master il est
notre spécialiste cyclisme mais bien
plus encore yann dujariet est avec nous
pendant une heure bonjour Yann comment
ça va très bien Mickaël
avec ça
on vous a pas trop manqué ah quand même
j'aime bien venir j'aime bien venir
j'aime bien parler de l'actu du coin et
puis et puis voilà mais en effet comme
vous ça m'a fait drôle d'entendre
champion du monde besoin de votre de
votre bouche est-ce que toi pendant
longtemps Mickaël disait vie champion
riche champion et c'est vrai que
maintenant je suis devenu champion du
monde
merci d'être avec nous en tout cas pour
aujourd'hui de l'autre côté musique à
gauche le guerrier à l'un des monuments
cette émission notre Grégory Aldric à
nous
et du Rugby Club de Versailles et il va
être content on va parler encore de
rugby aujourd'hui dans cette émission
c'est Pierre Chevalier notre gladiateur
qui est avec nous bonjour Pierre formule
bonheur à tous salut ça va pleine forme
ça va plein gaz si on se réfère à la
Rochelle et à cette magnifique
épopée en Coupe d'Europe souhaitons
qu'on fasse une meilleure mi-temps
qu'ils l'ont fait ou et puis ne pas
tenter la remontada mais en tout cas on
est aiguisé comme dégâts des dagues pour
parler rugby effectivement pour une
deuxième fois c'est très très bien
l'histoire de Toulon Challenge Cup
victoire de La Rochelle
pour pour la compétition qui va nous
intéresser à la fin de l'année sur le
toit de l'Europe ce rugby français on
repasse de l'autre côté musique son
statut de si nouveau ne tient plus
peut-être qu'il y a de batterie X est
imposé comme une valeur sûre de ce
collectif de si on parlait sport 8e
sélection pour lui il est le responsable
sponsoring chez Orange Île-de-France
amoureux de sport Philippe volak nous
fait l'honneur d'être avec nous une
nouvelle fois sur cette émission salut
Philippe comment allez-vous bonjour à
tous moi ça va impeccable impeccable on
est en plein dans la vidéo on dit encore
l'autre fois dans la dernière ligne
droite des des dernières journées de fou
de rugby va de tout moi pour Orange les
finales régionales de l'orange
aujourd'hui Football Challenge il y a
aussi l'orange Auby challenge aussi le
17 juin aussi
avec des équipes aussi des Yvelines donc
ouais à fond et le petit polo si on peut
vous pourquoi le polo sport copacion est
un petit clin d'oeil à notre ami commun
Lionel donc voilà et oui Yvelines noires
tout un lien avec les images on le
rappelle assez bien dans cette émission
et on termine de l'autre côté musique il
célèbre avec nous sa première cape dans
cette émission appelée de dernière
minute dans une liste de sélectionner du
Sep mais la qualité est là il revient
tout fraîchement tatoué de la
Nouvelle-Zélande ce sera passionné de
l'ovalier et surtout de rugby
neo-zélandais les journées chez TV 78
Nicolas Damry est avec nous bonjour
Nicolas bonjour je tiens à rassurer un
le haka c'est une danse carrière
guerrière traditionnellement mais c'est
aujourd'hui pour rendre hommage aux
familles néo-zélandaises au maori voilà
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait d'être sur
votre première émission si on parle
sport ah ben ça fait plaisir j'espère
que Michael regarde et puis il me diras
ce qu'il en pense et vous allez la tour
de tâche de me supplier à l'envoler tout
à l'heure je serai très vigilant Nicolas
tout à l'heure on va parler dans cette
émission de basket Victor when benyama
roi de la bête clique élite promis à la
NBA il va bientôt s'envoler à la NBA et
peut-être du côté des Spurs de San
Antonio c'est la destination très
probable après la loterie de la draft
pour livres Linois côté sport US aussi
on parlera de baseball avec les Cougars
de Montigny-le-Bretonneux a décidément
historique Roland-Garros ça approche et
cette année encore nos yvelinois seront
sur les cours de la Porte d'Auteuil
quels sont leurs chances nous poserons
la question et tout à l'heure également
au programme de la box et du rugby
yvelinois le rugby Villenoy à la fête
avec plusieurs montées pour nos clubs
yvelinois mais d'abord on va parler de
football et après les déboires du FC
Versailles c'était une thématique du
dernier SEP sport un autre club
yvelinois fait parler de lui dans
l'actualité la DNCG le gendarme du
football français gendarme financier
vient d'exclure laisse Poissy et du
championnat de National 2 le 4e échelon
national le club des Yvelines est en
proie des difficultés financières avec
un déficit de 230 000 € le club qui
évolue dans ce championnat depuis 2015
réalisé pourtant une saison correcte en
étant l'actuel 6e de la poule A de N2 on
va écouter tout de suite l'interview du
président Olivier sevesu qui a été
d'ailleurs réalisé par vous Nicolas
dandry
[Applaudissements]
excusez-moi je suis un peu énervé parce
que j'ai pas dormi de la nuit quand vous
passez devant une commission comme ça et
qui vous exclut et que vous recevez un
mail en disant que vous êtes exclu mais
je lui dis mais c'est une blague ce mot
exclusion c'est quoi c'est comme quand
j'ai des sans-papiers des gens comme ça
vous connaissez mon engagement je me
suis battu toute ma vie il y a SOS
Racisme et autres quand je vois ça et ce
mot exclu bien sûr que j'ai pleuré hier
les investisseurs m'ont dit tu sais tes
croyants quand même on te connaît
Olivier chou qu'on connait on sait très
bien que on te met à l'épreuve oui mais
les épreuves ça peut tuer je suis
exténué je suis fatigué et je vais curé
qu'on me lâche comme ça clairement la
DNCG m'a dit monsieur se mesure j'étais
avec mon trésorier hier vous savez
écartez-vous des politiques je les dire
monsieur carloli ce matin qui m'a fait
venir j'ai dit Carl c'est peut-être une
cabale
tu défends aujourd'hui le neveu de
monsieur le Président Monsieur Macron
qui est venu à Poissy on connaît la
proximité de Monsieur car le livre avec
le président ça n'a rien à voir
peut-être je lui ai dit maintenant tu
dois m'aider parce que j'ai rien fait
moi j'ai absolument rien fait je me suis
dit est-ce que c'est une chasse aux
sorcières monsieur car le livre qui m'a
fait venir il y a 6 ans m'appeler deux
fois ce matin j'arrivais au boulot très
tôt sur ma moto comme tous les matins si
je suis artisan et je travaille comme un
fou ça c'est entre parenthèses parce que
le football c'est du bénévolat j'y mets
de l'argent et j'ai voilà on s'est
compris
la problématique c'est que
nous sommes passés l'adncg
au mois de mars fin mars et on leur
expliquait mon expert-comptable et
moi-même et mon trésorier il y avait un
déficit de 150000 euros au 31 décembre
2022 on a depuis cette date-là chercher
des partenaires aujourd'hui ce club je
dirige depuis 6 ans on nous avait
prévenu que c'était compliqué puisque
n'oubliez pas qu'il y a eu l'histoire et
vous le savez de ces licences
malheureusement qui nous ont coûté 7
points et 34000 euros il y a eu ce
joueur monsieur Clément fantôme que
j'avais négocié à l'époque m'enlevant un
joueur qualité que j'avais été chercher
un grand joueur pour Chartres j'ai une
procédure contre charte 15000 euros ça
jamais été donné j'ai arrêté les
procédures parce que ça coûte plus cher
en
avocat que et j'obtiendrai jamais cette
somme en début d'année c'est-à-dire au
mois de septembre on m'a indiqué que
Veolia ne serait plus partenaire et
engie ils m'ont dit texto l'adncg et
j'ai des témoins président s vous avez
jusqu'au 10 juin très bien je leur ai
dit prenez soin de vous comme d'habitude
[Musique]
j'ai présenté des investisseurs j'ai
présenté beaucoup de gens depuis
quelques temps vous voyez des projets
sont là les très beaux projets refusés
on a un rendez-vous demain pour
évidemment quelque part on va faire on
va faire appel pour l'honneur du club
pour le mien pour montrer Aurier pour la
pour la ville même je reçois des
messages de Jean-Marc Pilorget de mes
amis du PSG etc
on connaît ma probité tous les jours me
disent Olivier c'est pour rien tu as
rien fait aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
d'être abandonné j'en ai après personne
mais j'ai la rage
[Applaudissements]
c'est où Nicolas qui avait recueilli ses
propos on le sent abattu le président de
l'espoir
pour ce club ça fait 6 ans qui est à la
tête de ce club c'est Carl l'olive qu'il
a amené
l'actuel
pour diriger ce club et puis il investit
de l'argent il travaille à côté il est
bénévoles comme il dit il investit de
son propre argent dans ce club donc oui
oui il est vraiment abattu donc en
attente des des possibles le recours sur
sur cette affaire alors il disait
Olivier sevesu qui a la saison a été
compliquée c'est le moins qu'on l'on
puisse dire pour les ce poisson qui
avait subi une pénalité il a évoqué de 7
points sur tapis vert en cause les
certificats médicaux sur les demandes de
licence de deux joueurs qui ne
présentaient pas les garanties
d'authenticité nécessaire le club va
donc normalement évoluer l'année
prochaine dans le championnat de de
régional une même si on est en attente
des recours voir s'ils aboutissent c'est
c'est recours la question que j'ai envie
de vous poser sur ce thème pour
commencer et ce que laisse possible va
s'enlever à votre avis de cet épisode
non pour mitigé également
trop tôt pour pouvoir avoir un avis je
veux dire l'ascension vient juste de
tomber
déjà ils ont jusqu'au 10 juin pour
pouvoir peut-être trouver une solution
c'est un délai relativement court mais
rien n'est rien n'est rien n'est figé
maintenant est-ce qu'ils vont s'en
relever ou pas de toute façon on se
relèvera à moyen ou long terme on se
relèvera pas du jour au lendemain et
puis si ils vont en R1 il faudra du
temps pour pouvoir remonter ça c'est sûr
après personne n'a de boule de cristal
et personne ne peut dire si quel en sera
l'avenir mais
quand on est enfin je me souviens avoir
été quand j'étais pilote dans l'athlète
handisport j'ai parti au championnat du
monde pareil sans aucune raison avoir
été remplacé par un par un autre par un
autre athlète sur le coup j'ai eu le
même sentiment qu'une
quand on s'est largué et ça a été dur et
c'est vrai que j'ai ça m'a fait ça m'est
fait penser parce que quand il dit que
en effet on peut tout arrêter juste
après ça parce que ça vous équerre mais
finalement après on trouve un nouvel
objectif et puis bah
parce qu'on est passionné on est
passionné par le sport et donc on trouve
de nouveau de nouveaux challenges à
pouvoir relever et c'est ça qui va c'est
ça qui nous fait avancer donc bah oui en
attente de voir pour pour les prochaines
décisions on attend de cette date du
jour il paye pas le président de Poissy
les coûts un peu clinquants qui a eu sur
ces dernières saisons avec Clément
chantault mais d'ailleurs une procédure
qui est en cours il a rappelé avec avec
Chartres l'avenue aussi Laurent Fournier
on s'en souvient sur le banc de Poissy
et aussi les liens avec car le livre le
maire de précis il y a peut-être un coup
aussi l'ancien maire de Poissy peut-être
un coup politique aussi et derrière
cette décision c'est ce qui en tout cas
et c'est c'est motif de son accusation
je suis complètement d'accord avec ça
faut penser aussi qu'il y a pas que
Poissy il y a d'autres clubs aussi de
National 2 qui ont eu la même la même
sanction aussi
je crois il y a d'autres d'autres clubs
aussi mais c'est le terme exclu qui je
pense qu'il fait mal au Président je
sais ce que c'est j'ai été aussi
président de président de club mais
exclu c'est pas euh séparer trop gradé
c'est exclu exclu c'est c'est violent
c'est violent et d'un coup voilà là il
réagit à chose qui est tout à fait
logique en espérant que voilà que mes
soeur va être dur si c'est 300000 euros
ou je sais pas combien ça va être ça va
quand même être difficile la difficulté
c'est pour répondre à la question c'est
que c'est qu'il ne semble pas avoir
toutes les cartes en main c'est-à-dire
que là là on a on a un homme bénévole et
on l'est on l'est quasiment tous dans
nos sports respectifs on a des métiers à
côté c'est du temps consacré c'est de
l'énergie c'est de la passion le plus
souvent le plus souvent et quand on a
quand on a un un
navire et un coup près qui tombe comme
celui-là c'est euh là c'est l'abattement
c'est l'abattement qu'on a qu'on a
ressenti ressenti chez lui c'était
vraiment très palpable et puis c'est
surtout la suite effectivement Watt next
et quels sont quels sont les moyens
qu'il a de maintenir son club au niveau
où il a amené les projets qu'il a
préparé avec des investisseurs avec des
partenaires qui a priori son balayés
d'un revers de d'un revers de manche
voilà et il continue à mettre de
l'énergie au service de son club par
passion et malgré ça c'est l'impression
sans avoir nous non plus toutes les
cartes en main c'est qu'on lui met des
bâtons dans les roues il y a peut-être
effectivement quelques quelques petits
inimitiers quelques petites illimités et
quelques et quelques conséquences de de
la de l'exposition du club de Poissy et
de la ville de Poissy
Dieu sait que car Lee qui est donc
député maintenant qui a été maire maire
de Poissy qui était qui était dans les
spots dans les sports à Canal avant à
une à une légitimité à une aura et donc
effectivement ce que les prises de
position qu'il fait qu'il prend qu'il
prend des conséquences et même même dans
les dans les clubs amateurs de son côté
donc là en conclusion c'est c'est les
difficultés que l'on a tous et toutes
quand on est quand on est aux affaires
dans des clubs amateurs et qu'on fait
avec les moyens du bord et que et qui a
certains moments où en gros ça ça passe
pas les règlements quoi bien sûr dans
les prochains jours avec attention
c'était une première réaction qu'on
avait aujourd'hui parce que l'actualité
toute fraîche elle a été elle nous est
parvenue la nuit dernière concernant
cette sanction qui concerne le club de
Poissy et on va passer à présent à notre
page débat
[Musique]
et on attendait tous ce moment je pense
avec impatience autour de la table dans
la nuit du 16 au 17 mai aux alentours de
2h du matin la loterie de la draft NBA
le prestigieux championnat de basket
américain a livré son verdict les Spurs
de San Antonio décroche le premier choix
pour sélectionner un jeune espoir du
basket en vue de la saison prochaine la
franchise texane devrait donc recruter
sauf grande surprise le 22 juin prochain
jour de la draft livelinois Victor web
banyama qui est premier une place de
numéro 1 livre les noix de 19 ans c'est
de mettre 21 ça peut être donc à marcher
dans les pas de Tony Parker quatre
titres de NBA avec les Spurs entre 2003
et 2014 d'autres Français comme Boris
dio qu'on peut citer sont aussi à passer
par les Spurs la question est-ce que
c'est la destination
idyllique pour Victor web benyama
l'espérance de San Antonio
on a on a on a du oui oui mais oui mais
oui mais on va vous donner la parole il
y aura un petit duel bah on va faire un
petit duel entre Pierre et Yann on va
recommencer avec vous pierre alors
idyllique parce que oui parce que pour
l'histoire et pour la et pour la le
statut de l'équipe de San Antonio
l'histoire c'est évidemment le parallèle
le parallèle facile à faire avec Tony
Parker et
une équipe qui même si elle n'a plus le
faste qu'elle a eu il y a il y a une
dizaine d'années une quinzaine d'années
avec quand même pas mal de titres quand
même de la continuité notamment avec the
Pops avec le
coach le coach de historique de San
Antonio
elle est quand même en bonne place dans
le cœur des des fans de basket et de NBA
et puis et puis quand même dans les dans
la conférence dans la Conférence Ouest
avec le avec quand même quelques bons
résultats et pourquoi
pourquoi c'est mieux que les trois
autres que l'on a vu que que San Antonio
prenne le firspix c'est c'est justement
pour cette ce challenge ce challenge et
et le goût des Français aussi qu'on les
les habitants de San Antonio je retire
moi le au moment de au moment du
firstick de San Antonio à la fois la
réaction de l'équipe du staff de Victor
et de sa famille aussi qui était en
direct dans un endroit secret à Paris
qui était en direct et bien surtout
celui des fans de San Antonio qui était
mais comme des dingues c'est comme s'ils
avaient déjà gagné le championnat de
championnat NBA 2024 donc ça c'est c'est
du tout bon pour notre pour notre pépite
yvelinoise le Mbappe du basket c'est ce
qu'a dit le président de l'universel on
le rappelle c'est son premier club c'est
là qu'il a commencé le le basketteur
pourquoi oui mais pourquoi le met
surtout Yann alors oui pour tout ce que
tu viens de dire et mets tout simplement
parce que alors déjà le fait d'être tiré
numéro 1 enfin d'être le premier de la
draft fait que vous allez il va avoir
une pression
quand il va arriver
en fait deux grands noms qui vont parler
forcément aux adeptes du basket David
Robinson et Tim Duncan sont deux grands
champions qu'on tous les deux étaient
titrés en NBA et aussi MVP de la Ligue
il figure aujourd'hui d'ailleurs au sein
du du hall donc ça laisserait peur quand
même ouais c'est clair et puis là
maintenant ce qui peut leur je connais
pas tellement les histoires de transfert
qui peut y avoir au sein de de cette
ligne mais c'est vrai que là bon bah les
Spurs ils grimpent en échelon avec la
future pépite mondiale certainement du
du basket donc là ça va certainement
aussi peut-être avoir un effet
aimant pour pour d'autres qui voudront
jouer avec ou peut-être contre
d'ailleurs c'est ce que disait aussi une
interview avec lui bien sûr chroniqueur
du Sep sportif qui disait que il allait
être placé au centre du projet il y a
tout un nouveau projet qui va être
construit autour de one byama Philippe
qui vous a convaincu entre Pierre et
Yann même si finalement les arguments se
rejoignent quand même ça se rejoint
quand même ça se rejoint quand même tous
les deux il y a il y a du
donc le parallèle sera peut-être plus en
tout cas peut-être de la part des
américains avec Tim Duncan et nous en
France on fera peut-être le parallèle
plus avec Tony
parkerich c'est aussi le choix fort
alors on va voir s'il va rester au sport
parce qu'il a 74 ans mais 2127 matchs de
NBA même si au tout début il était connu
pour ça on va dire ça dureté au final
maintenant on le voit plus comme un
entraîneur qui a fait progresser les
joueurs qu'il a eu dans son équipe et
s'allonge éviter par le parle pour
lui-même là on a on a une pépite qui est
qui est un joueur
ultra complet j'allais dire malgré sa
taille parce que c'est vrai que à 2 M21
de voir de voir un un
garçon si à l'aise techniquement aux
dribbles au shooting distance c'est
juste c'est juste ça aussi ou Mike
parler aussi de de piste d'amélioration
pour pour wembi c'est justement le les
tirs à trois points mais dans la
raquette aussi au rebond donc et avec un
expert avec un entraîneur expérimenté
comme popovitch après c'est là ça va
être ça va être une alchimie absolument
phénoménale et là on peut dire
définitivement définitivement dire que
son Antonio a de la chance d'avoir eu le
choix dans la draft son défi
de Victoria de prendre de la masse aussi
parce qu'on sait que c'est très rude le
championnat de NBA ça fait 4 ans c'est
vrai que cette saison alors les saisons
précédentes on avait pu dire qu'il était
souvent handicapé par les blessures
cette saison ça était plutôt celle de la
régularité avec les mètres 92
en ligue de basket en effet c'était
c'était
bonifier il va se bonifier avec lui du
volume
trophées de la saison LNB il a donc pris
tous les les gros trophées celui de MVP
notamment au total 5 trophées sur sur
cette saison de LNB il a il a tout raté
où Victor web benyama on a l'impression
quand même Philippe ouais c'est la
saison de l'explosion définitive avant
de partir en NBA
il va falloir confirmer en NBA faire
mieux il sait pas blessé il a il a été
bon à tous les niveaux oui c'est voilà
mais je reste sur quand même sur mon
truc j'ai hâte de voir les premiers
matchs parce que ça va être parce que là
ça joue encore beaucoup plus
physiquement
dans un premier temps il va y avoir il
va il va repartir à zéro c'est à dire
que là maintenant oui en effet pendant
une saison il a joué il a joué il était
plus elle a LMB était plus adapté à One
Piece
et aux figuré la ligne de la reprendre
justement des peut-être temps de jeu de
5 10 minutes par-ci par là pour pouvoir
s'acclimater à cette à ce nouveau rythme
on le voit là quand il quand il quand il
joue euh ouais il est tranquille là il
va falloir accélérer
cette saison à 21,6 points 10,4 bon 2,4
passe décisives 0,7 interception et
Victor web benyama qui est engagé
toujours un pour les playoffs de Betclic
élite avec les mètres 92 de Boulogne le
Valois il joueront ce jeudi un troisième
match contre Cholet pour se qualifier en
demi-finale on rappelle que la draft
c'est le 22 juin prochain et donc Victor
web benyama sauve grande surprise sauf
énorme surprise devrait donc rejoindre
les Spurs de San Antonio on va rester
messieurs dans la thématique des sports
américains des sports US avec cette
performance historique des Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux équipe de
baseball bien sûr basé dans les Yvelines
les inné montains se sont imposés sur le
score de 9 manches à 4 face au ski de
Rouen dans le tournoi du Challenge de
France ils ont donc remporté ce
Challenge de France qui se déroulait en
Seine-et-Marne le week-end dernier les
cougars qui décrochent ainsi leur ticket
pour le championnat européen c'est la
deuxième fois de leur histoire à noter
que le lanceur de de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux originaire du
Venezuela ayeur Frank Lopez a été nommé
MVP de la compétition un avis sur sur
cette performance et ce qu'il alors la
question est peut-être un peu forte
est-ce qu'il rentre dans l'histoire du
baseball français je sais pas mais en
tout cas une marque le sport yvelinois
avec cette performance votre réponse
après voilà
ça reste un sport ça reste un sport
mineur par l'histoire du baseball
alors pourquoi il rentre dans l'histoire
les cougars
je me disais déjà comment je veux dire
il est pas très connu c'est a fait une
bonne pub pour ça pas une bonne pub pour
ce sport je trouve que c'est que c'est
bien je regardais aussi au même niveau
ils ont chez les féminines une qui est
une présélectionnée pour l'équipe de
France et c'est c'est un bon c'est déjà
bien il rentre quand même dans
l'histoire parce que c'est la première
fois qu'ils ont une présélectionnée ou
un présélectionné en équipe de France je
crois que c'est que c'est bien les
jeunes ça tourne bien aussi là les
résultats qu'ils ont fait au Tournoi de
France enfin ça a été au Challenge de
France a été super je dirais ils ont eu
du mal à passer en demi-finale et il y a
eu besoin d'une belle ou voilà mais la
finale c'est quand même Rouen c'est
comme les plus costauds sont pas un
tournoi en dehors de la saison régulière
qui réunit les meilleurs clubs français
et effectivement ils sont imposés
d'ailleurs Nicolas face à Rouen en
finale qui est quand même 17 fois
champion de France
deuxième de la poule derrière le Stade
Toulousain c'est surprenant d'ailleurs
de voir le groupe
rugby mais ouais c'est une équipe
sérieuse quand même
Montigny dans la poule et 3e juste
derrière orange justement donc ça peut
les galvaniser pour la fin de la saison
après peut-être pas dans l'histoire les
couleurs peut-être pas dans l'histoire
mais en tout cas c'est leur histoire qui
sont en train d'écrire participation
championnat européen l'année prochaine
ça sera intéressant de suivre comment
ils évoluent dans ce championnat donc
oui oui c'est c'est quelque chose de
bien pour pour le club en tout cas il a
utilisé le mot galvaniser on a parlé la
dernière fois de la disparition Dany
couteau l'ancienne président forcément
dans toutes les têtes des joueurs de
Montigny il y a aussi une nouvelle
équipe à la tête de président avec José
darrojo le nouveau président vous pensez
qu'il peut être galvanisé ce groupe en
vue de la fin de saison leur objectif
c'est d'aller en play enfin
de toute façon des étapes importantes
comme les par exemple type de
comparaison la Coupe de France pour le
football bon évidemment toute proportion
gardée parce que pour répondre à votre
question c'est simplement parler de
l'histoire du championnat de baseball en
France du championnat de baseball
français qui est plus qui est plus sur
lequel il est plus difficile de se tuer
mais en tout état de cause c'est comme
dit Philippe c'est ça donne aussi un
coup de projecteur sur sur une équipe
déjà une équipe locale donc ça dès qu'il
y a des résultats dans les Yvelines on
est on est content et en plus d'aller
gratter un petit peu les champions
normaux de Rouen c'est c'est aussi à la
fois une performance et et sans doute un
beau point de départ avec justement
cette ce capital émotionnel qui a eu sur
les sur les dernières semaines au club
de Montigny qui doit leur permettre oui
de transformer en fait de transformer
cette cette énergie cette énergie ses
émotions en énergie positive et puis
essayer de porter un peu plus haut
encore le baseball en France donc Yann
oui belle performance ma relat utiliser
parce que le baseball en France n'a pas
une place prépondérante exactement voilà
tout à fait et je trouve ça dommage
parce que
pour avoir eu la chance alors pas
d'avoir vu en direct mais d'avoir pu
voir des matchs de baseball à la télé ça
reste quand même un sport très sympa et
très très télévision aux États-Unis
c'est voilà ça fait partie des semaines
voilà même si c'est le troisième sport
dans dans la dans la hiérarchie avec la
NFL et la et la
NHL c'est ça voilà c'est sur glace non
alors NFL
dans la dans dans la hiérarchie
je trouve juste dommage c'est que on a
quand même un stade qui est en plein
centre-ville
on a un stade là les studios on est à
500 mètres de leur de leur couteau du
nom de l'ancienne président
est-ce que est-ce qu'il va y avoir
possibilité d'accueillir du public quand
ils vont et quand il va y avoir des
matchs de Coupe d'Europe
je connais pas la capacité des tribus
mais c'est vrai qu'elles sont petites
quand même et ce qu'il faut tout faire
pour attirer du monde je sens parce que
c'est la deuxième fois dans leur
histoire qui vont être en championnat
d'Europe je suis désolé mais en effet on
doit communiquer et on doit donner envie
aux gens enfin c'est ça va être des
matchs de Coupe d'Europe c'est à dire
que si c'était un match de Coupe
d'Europe de foot qui avait lieu sur 50
ans en Yvelines ça déplacerait des
foules énormes là je suis désolé c'est
un sport ça reste le même le même niveau
ça reste le même la demande
d'investissement de la part des des gens
qui qui pratiquent ce sport c'est la
même chose on se doit de se rendre quand
on est à proximité surtout que ça va
être
gratuit les accès pour pouvoir les voir
j'imagine donc ou avec des faibles des
très faibles coûts si vous voulez voir
un match de foot de Coupe d'Europe c'est
pas les voilà on va parler des JO mais
voilà c'est quand même donc là c'est
rendre accessible du sport de haut
niveau au plus grand nombre et ça je
trouve que bah oui en effet il faut
communiquer et il faut donner de l'info
moi j'ai participé au ce week-end à des
Interclubs il y avait des athlètes de
niveau international qui était présent
je me suis dit après mais pourquoi
est-ce que il est à plus de monde de
spectateurs alors c'est une super
ambiance d'interclubs en athlé c'est
génial l'offre est important après tous
les sports super important super mais
voilà c'est vrai que des fois à
proximité de chez soi et ben il peut y
avoir des choses à voir quand on est
passionné de sport et on en a pas
toujours l'information c'est ça que je
veux c'est ça que je veux s'il y a du
public ou pas pour ce championnat
d'Europe en attendant je vous disais le
championnat de D1 qui se poursuit avec
la réception des boucaniers de La
Rochelle le week-end prochain les
cougars son troisième sur cinq de leurs
poules vise les playoffs pour la fin de
saison pour de faire il faut terminer
deuxième de la poule et il reste 8
journées de championnat vous êtes
confiants ils vont ils peuvent le faire
ils sont dans une bonne dynamique déjà
je voulais aussi c'est une continuité
quand même on parle quand même deux
assez régulièrement avec de bonnes
informations
contrairement à d'autres sports US de du
secteur ouais voilà le lever de trophée
de la part des Cougars de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux bonne fin de
saison eux et bravo pour cette victoire
dans le Challenge de France on va parler
messieurs à présent de tennis qui dit
fin du mois de mai dit et je sais que
certains sont impatients autour de la
table autour de Roland Garros l'édition
2023 se déroule du 29 mai au 11 juin
pour le tournoi principal bien sûr
puisque les qualifications ont démarré
depuis le 22 mai des yvelinois seront
sur la terre battue parisienne et on
pense en premier lieu à Caroline Garcia
la numéro 5 mondiale la
saint-germainoise de 29 ans on se titres
en carrière avec une année 2022
fantastique on s'en souvient quatre
tournois remportés dont le wt le début
de saison est plus compliqué cette année
aucun titre pour le moment de finale
perdu au Mexique et à Lyon la semaine
dernière elle a été éliminée dès le
troisième tour des Internationaux
d'Italie à Rome et l'année dernière elle
avait terminé seulement une deuxième un
deuxième tour à la vérité au deuxième
tour de Roland Garros côté messieurs on
peut citer forcément notre yvelinois
Arthur rinderknech qui a du mal à surfer
il faut le dire sur sa magnifique année
2021 4 titres challenger mais sur le
circuit ATP l'actuel 78e mondial a du
mal à franchir un cap il est éliminé dès
les premiers tours des tournois auxquels
il participe cette semaine il a été
éliminé dès le deuxième tour du tournoi
de Lyon et l'an passé à Roland-Garros
Arthur Riner je n'avais pas réussi à
franchir le premier tour ESCA votre avis
les les Yvelines peuvent briller sur sur
cette quinzaine à Roland-Garros c'est
l'année où j'avais c'est l'année ou
jamais mais oui
Raphaël n'est pas là il y a un nom de la
partie qui représentera le nom
[Musique]
entre Pierre et Yann on va faire le duel
entre Nicolas et Philippe et on va
commencer à aller avec Nicolas pourquoi
oui pourquoi ils peuvent mieux parce que
comme le Diane c'est peut-être l'année
notamment pour Caroline Garcia qui a
fait une très bonne année 2022 début
d'année 2023 peut-être compliqué mais
peut-être compliqué parce que elle veut
être en forme pour Roland-Garros c'est
du coup ça monte en puissance
progressivement petit à petit et
peut-être que c'est pendant
Roland-Garros qu'elle va performer et
qu'elle va réussir à attirer son épingle
du jeu on attend encore un une grosse
performance sur un tournoi du Grand
Chelem pour Caroline Garcia au maximum
les demi-finales ça lui est Open c'est
ça et puis à la maison galvanisé par le
public
donc à voir à voir ce que comment ça ça
peut enfin pour moi moi je pense que
Caroline Garcia peut tirer son épingle
du jeu sur ce Roland Garros après côté
masculin c'est un peu plus compliqué
Arthur and darkness
exactement il est rentré dans le top 100
mondial mais sur le circuit ATP sur les
tournois ATP
on a quand même un Français qui qui va
un peu plus loin quand même
en deuxième semaine quand même c'est
vrai je veux dire exceptionnellement
c'est vrai quand même mais voilà faut
attendre moi je dis moi je bon j'y serai
deux fois peut-être mais je me dis je
suis vraiment dans l'inconnu j'ai hâte
de j'ai hâte de voir ça chaque année en
fait on est on a on est plein d'espoir
bon déjà on est comme des dingues parce
que il y a eu deux années covid mais on
est comme des dingue à chaque printemps
fin mai début juin parce que ça il y a
le Festival de Cannes et puis après et
puis après il y a Roland Garros il y a
le Grand Prix de Monaco voilà
c'est c'est c'est
une belle période pour le sport pour les
Français à Roland-Garros c'est cette
espèce d'Everest ce plafond de verre qui
est qu'on n'arrive pas à franchir depuis
1983 c'est
le dernier le siècle le dernier voilà 40
ans que que c'est imposé heureusement il
y a eu des Françaises chez les dames qui
se sont imposés
avec Pierce notamment mais mais
Marie-France a percé et hélas
à chaque fois on fait l'état des lieux
de nos chances en la matière je je pluss
pour Caroline Garcia qui est notre
meilleur chance de de d'un bon trajet
dans dans le tableau féminin côté homme
effectivement on sort un petit peu les
atouts qu'on a Lucas Pouille est passé
au premier tour là hier soir il est
comme il a passé son premier son tour de
calife de calife bon voilà Arthur ça
fait longtemps qu'on attend qu'il qu'il
confirme et le maximum c'est un deuxième
tour
pour rebondir sur ce que disait nicolas
c'est pour moi Roland Garros les
Français Roland-Garros c'est à double
tranchant soit ils sont galvanisés
effectivement ils peuvent être ils
peuvent être poussés par le par le
public de la Porte d'Auteuil soit mon
fils par exemple ou alors ils sont
complètement ils sont complètement
tétanisés tétanisés par l'enjeu et
dépasser par cette pression de 40 ans
qui existe depuis la victoire de noir
bon par contre on va pousser on va
pousser derrière allez carreaux allez
allez Arthur elle est Lucas au son on
sait jamais et puis on verra on verra
bien il y en a il y en a effectivement
toujours un qui fait quand même un petit
bout de trajet votre avis ne ratez pas
les premiers tours si vous voulez voir
jouer les Français voilà ne soyez
présent soyez présents le premier
dimanche le lundi et le mardi parce
qu'après ça va être compliqué non mais
alors oui on a toujours espoir parce que
c'est vrai que on est ultra Chauvin mais
là vous dites ça fait 40 ans mais moi je
me souviens quand même de belles années
à Roland-Garros même si on n'a pas
toujours on a pas gagné depuis mais on a
eu il y a eu très belle de très belles
demi-finales et puis final avec forgé
etc il y a eu des belles des belles
épopées voilà mais c'est vrai que depuis
quelques depuis une dizaine d'années
quand on a un français en 2e semaine on
est content donc là c'est un peu
difficile et sincèrement je vois pas
comment cette année ça pourrait être
autrement j'espère bien sûr que ce sera
qui nous feront des qui nous feront
mentir j'adorerais que Arthur passe un
deuxième ou troisième tour ce serait ce
serait amplement mérité parce que je
pense pas que le garçon soit soit
feignant à l'entraînement je pense que
c'est c'est c'est c'est vraiment un
bagarreur et donc oui en effet ce serait
en plus ce serait une une ouverture au
grand public parce que c'est ça c'est
aujourd'hui nous on parle de lui parce
qu'il est il est des il est des Yvelines
il est connu dans la sphère du tennis
mais comme vous Briez en tant que
Français à Roland-Garros là c'est vous
deux donnez une autre rare voilà
exactement et puis du coup après c'est
un aussi un déc lencheur pour pour
d'autres choses voilà c'est l'année pour
parce que Ben monsieur
zut Nadal Rafael Nadal ne sera pas au
départ maintenant je crois que les
Espagnols envoient envoie un remplaçant
qui s'appelle alkara
ils sont malins c'est-à-dire qu'il y en
a qui s'en va on en amène à nouveau les
liaison
je ne pense pas que ce soit la formation
qui soit mauvaise en tout cas c'est
super c'est super ouvert parce que avec
un petit pass qui est à fond il y a des
routes
[Musique]
il a perdu tout à Monaco donc voilà non
moi je un petit pronostic alors du coup
très rapidement c'est dur bah moi pour
moi ouais alkara si je dois donner un ce
sera le 15 Philippe
je sais pas
toujours souvent le même dernier carré
là et ça se tient ça se tient à rien du
tout
aucune idée on verra l'espagnoles qui
peut prendre le relais
en général
ça change régulièrement de vainqueur
côté femme un mot peut-être juste sur
nos jeunes pousses civilinoises qui
étaient engagés dès cette semaine dans
le tour les tours des qualifications et
cette belle performance a souligner
quand même au premier tour la
qualification de Margot Rouvroy 22 ans
ancienne licencié du Tennis Club de
plaisir une victoire face à Sofia
akennin américain en août une heure 39
de jeu j'en perds mon latin de 7 6 4 6 4
et face à elle pourtant un kenyin la
finaliste de Roland Garros 2020
vainqueur de l'US Open la même année
Margot Rouvroy malheureusement qui a été
éliminé au deuxième tour des califes par
la biélorus shimanovitch Antoine Guy
Baudot lui a été éliminé dès le premier
tour par le Slovaque gombo
103.7.6 3 6 1 6 tout comme Margot
Rouvroy c'était une première lors du
tournoi de Roland Garros chez les grands
puisque lui il a déjà officier du côté
des juniors il a bénéficié d'une Walker
pour venir participer à ce tournoi et
enfin les derniers espoirs en
qualification sont pour la versaillesse
Chloé paquet tondeuse au premier tour de
l'espagnol bensons
elle joue en ce moment même au moment où
on enregistre cette émission contre une
autre espagnol bolsova au deuxième tour
de ces qualifications très rapidement
c'est une belle expérience on va retenir
avant tout ça parce que ils n'iront pas
dans le tableau principal peut-être que
les paquets à suivre belle expérience
déjà en plus on élimine une ancienne
finaliste de Roland-Garros pour pour
2020 et donc c'est une très bonne
expérience et espérons qu'on puisse en
parler je passe dans quelques années de
ces jeunes pousses
la
qualifications
[Rires]
et ben un petit peu comme pour on va
attendre le tirage au sort comme pour
comme pour la draft parce que ça joue
aussi ça joue aussi je veux dire vous
rencontrez le tableau de le tableau joue
aussi et je trouve que pas Victor arthur
n'a pas de chance dans les tirages au
sort on verra bien pour avoir en tout
cas sur les jeunes pousses mais c'est
toujours intéressant pour des jeunes
sportifs de toucher le haut niveau
d'aller sur place de prendre aussi
contact avec l'atmosphère qui peut
régner sur
un tournoi légendaire comme Roland
Garros donc c'est c'est une bonne
expérience à prendre et qui peut servir
après parce qu'on connaît justement
l'atmosphère de cette de ce du site même
si c'est pas la même ambiance que lors
du tournoi principal bien évidemment et
donc le tableau principal débute la
semaine prochaine dans la semaine du 29
mai rendez-vous le 10 juin pour la
finale dame et le 11 juin pour la finale
messieurs c'est l'heure de parler de
rugby dans le SEP
[Musique]
une fin de saison champagne on peut le
dire pour le rugby vlinois le 22 mai
dernier à un club officialisé son retour
en Fédérale 2 10 ans après son dernier
passage dans le sixième échelon national
le MLS GP maison Lafitte
Saint-Germain-en-Laye Poissy à valider
sa promotion après sa victoire en 16e de
finale contre Cavaillon les Yvelinois
c'était incliné à l'aller 17 13 mais
longtemps porté à domicile au retour 25
18 ils vont donc rejoindre la saison
prochaine en Fédérale 2 le club de
Versailles bien sûr et également plaisir
vous les connaissez bien vous lui LML GP
vous les avez joué la saison dernière en
tout cas on se connaît très très bien
c'est
un bon signe pour le rugby Villenoy pour
deux raisons le premier ça prouve
justement le niveau global du rugby qui
est pratiqué dans les Yvelines par ces
trois clubs qui sont des habitués de des
divisions fédérales on a souvent
guerroyer ensemble en fédéral 3 et puis
plaisir et monter ensuite en fédéral 2
il y a cette saison et donc là on va
tous se retrouver là deuxième deuxième
bon signe c'est cette stabilité cette
stabilité à bon niveau ou avec cette
redistribution des poules avec le
nivellement par le haut où on retrouve
en fait le niveau qu'il y avait en
Fédérale 3 il y a 5 6 ans là qu'on va
retrouver en Fédérale 2 force c'est de
constater que selon toute vraisemblance
on devrait se retrouver dans la même
poule donc avec avec au moins des derby
des derbios en couleur pour les Yvelines
on se connaît bien
au-delà de la rivalité départementale
voire régionale avec la en Île-de-France
il y a quand même un respect un respect
de ces trois clubs les a envers les
autres ça bosse bien il y a des écoles
de rugby qui sont qui sont nombreuses
qui sont de qualité et on a des
éducateurs qui qui font le job et
il faut dire que non seulement il y a
les équipes fanions qui qui performent
avec là cette montée du mlgp en Fédérale
2 plaisir qui est depuis longtemps et
nous avec la qualification
en barrage en une et en deux mais il y a
aussi des résultats chez les jeunes chez
des juniors chez les cadets dans les
écoles de rugby donc on pratique un bon
rugby et puis et puis tout le monde
bosse vraiment dans le même sens pour
former de bonjour à de rugby et qui sont
qui vont être la confronter les uns aux
autres la saison prochaine en Fédérale 2
théoriquement dans la même poule dans
ton sens pierre on a reçu Baptiste
Lemery l'autre jour le capitaine de
l'équipe seigneur de MLSGP il a joué à
plaisir alors souvent en plus c'est que
les joueurs se connaissent en sélection
départementale quand ils sont jeunes
c'est la porte à côté et ensuite il se
transfert de club en club donc certains
joueurs ont joué à Versailles avant
d'aller à la msgp où l'on joue à plaisir
et puis ils sont allés à Versailles
ensuite donc et c'est la joie également
aussi pour le club de Chevreuse qui
évoluera la saison prochaine dans le
championnat de Fédérale 3 les Yvelinois
ce sont qualifiés en plus pour les 8e de
finale de régional une après leur
victoire le 22 mai contre Créteil 43 20
le score final sur un terrain neutre à
Massy on ajoute à cela la qualification
au barrage de Versailles que Pierre
évoquait pour la première saison du club
en Fédérale 2 une saison historique le
parcours de plaisir également fait final
même s'il est élimination en 16e de
finale peut laisser peut-être quelques
regrets face à à Saint-Priest la
question que j'ai envie de vous poser
est-ce qu'on peut parler de saison
parfaite pour le rugby baignoire ou
quasi parfaitement
vous êtes tous d'accord on vous a pas
encore entendu Philippe et Yann pourquoi
bah pourquoi c'est parfait je trouve que
il y a une super résultats malgré
l'élimination de plaisir un peu
prématurée
et gagne d'un point là-bas quand même
c'était pas c'était pas évident quand
même bon ils avaient 8 mois 8 à l'aller
mais moi je trouve que les Yvelines
reviennent sur les par rapport au
département ils reviennent par rapport
au 92 car aussi de bon club le 91 où je
me dis moi trois clubs Massy Ris-Orangis
et Orsay je trouve que les Yvelines
montent bien même par rapport aux 95
tout je trouve que
ouais ouais je suis ces résultats et une
dynamique il y a une dynamique et c'est
bien c'est top pour le département
si tout le monde est dans la même pour
bien sûr oui voilà encore une fois il y
a des chances géographique ça devrait se
passer comme ça d'accord c'est pas des
tirages au sort
surtout surtout depuis quelques années
la Fédération essaye de faire des des
découpages géographiques pour diminuer
et diminuer les coûts de transport donc
là cette année on avait une poule qui
était surtout francilienne avec des
clubs de l'Ouest de oui plutôt ouest et
nord-ouest là ça pourrait aller vers
l'est vers la Bourgogne par exemple de
là il y a une base de 6 ou 7 clubs
franciliens potentiellement ce sera très
bien parce que du coup ça pourra
justement aider à l'accession à la à la
marche supérieure même si Jean le dit et
Pierre aussi toujours que la marche est
très très haute
et sur le terrain aussi
sur le terrain moi je parle d'abord on
est là pour parler de sport on n'est pas
là pour parler politique mais voilà
d'abord d'abord sur le terrain voilà il
y a quand même un gros gros une grosse
grosse marge donc du coup le meilleur
prétendant à la rigueur ce serait
plaisir parce que ça fait quand même
maintenant
cette saison qui sont voilà ouais cette
saison qui sont Fédérale 2 donc ce
serait peut-être bon moment pour
ce qu'on part sportivement par exemple
sur le sur la fédérale 2 et c'est eux
qui ont eu la les saisons les plus
régulières à ce niveau là et et
Maisons-Laffitte et nous sommes sommes
les petits poucets de la fédérale 2 mais
voilà pour faire voilà
bravo staff bravo joueur et très
rapidement sur le niveau de régional une
à Fédérale 3 pour Chevreuse est-ce que
le gap est grand et ce qu'ils peuvent se
stabiliser il est plus trop grand comme
il y a eu un nivellement par le haut la
fédérale 2 = Fédérale 3 en gros et donc
la l'ex honneur donc régional par
rapport à la Fédérale 3 la marche est un
peu moins haute mais là aussi il faut
saluer la très belle saison de des
chevrotins avec tu le préciser le pas
mal de joueurs de d'anciens joueurs de
Versailles qui jouent à Chevreuse
d'anciens joueurs d'Orphée aussi qui
sont venus grossir les rangs de cette
équipe de Chevreuse et qui là je mets un
petit billet peut aller très loin facile
à là ils sont ils ont une ils ont une
très belle dynamique cette saison ils
peuvent ils peuvent aller relativement
longs en phase finale je leur souhaite
le meilleur j'en profite également pour
dire que sur le rugby francilien on a un
tournoi départemental minimes U14 le
samedi 10 juin à Versailles avec tous
les clubs tous les clubs des Yvelines
représentés le message est passé
Chevreuse qui sera opposé à l'US Saintes
pour ces 8e de finale de régional une et
le MLS GP
ce sera opposé à Sarlat des rencontres
qui se disputent sur terrain neutre on
le rappelle pas de réception ou de
déplacement s'il y aura forcément des
placements mais en tout cas ce sera pas
à domicile face à
adversaire le rugby Villenoy à la fête
décidément Nicolas parce que les les
rugbymen et rugby woman le sont
également c'est c'est l'objet de votre
envolée du jour je vous laisse rubrique
les clés du camion allez-y je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui des 3B les pépites la
crème du rugby yvelin les 3B bah c'est
Boulard barré ben megal un trio 100 %
3/4 et je suppose que vous les
connaissez autour de la table je sais
pas présentation en images on commence
par la plus âgée le diamant du rugby
féminin Emily Boulard 23 ans elle joue
numéro 15 ou numéro 11 elle est
originaire de Rambouillet formé à
Chilly-Mazarin et les volumes maintenant
dans le Sud-Ouest à Blagnac dans la
banlieue toulousaine deux chiffres à
retenir la concernant elle a inscrit 11
essais en 23 sélections avec le 15 de
France féminin il y a ensuite la perle
versaillesse de 20 ans Léo barré pur
produit du Rugby Club de Versailles et
un pierre son père Arnaud tu as dû jouer
avec lui à jouer dans la cité royale et
même son grand-père aujourd'hui il joue
demi d'ouverture ou arrière avec les le
Soldat Rose du Stade Français Paris de
nombreux apparitions en Top 14 depuis
son arrivée dans la capitale en 2021
pour cette saison 2022 2023 et bien il a
joué de nombreux matchs et inscrits de
nombreux points pour rappel le Stade
Français occupe la troisième place du
classement les Parisiens les Parisiens
sont assurés de jouer les phases finales
de Top 14 on va savoir s'ils vont
recevoir pour les barrages ce weekend
c'est la dernière journée voilà en
fonction des résultats il joue à La
Rochelle alors attention parce que la
Rochelle chow-chow c'est à double
tranchant soit ils ont fêté un peu trop
le titre donc ça va être un peu
portugais soit ils sont dans la
dynamique et ça peut faire mal pour les
Parisiens à La Rochelle enfin c'est
l'éclair venu de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Enzo Benegal
19 ans formé au skyrugby un ailier
prometteur pour le rugby français le 50
nino a connu ces deux premières
sélections avec l'équipe de France moins
de 20 ans lors du tournoi des 6 nations
2023 face à l'Italie l'Irlande avec deux
essais inscrits sur les deux rencontres
joueurs du Racing 92 il a aussi Brié en
tout début de saison deuxième journée
face à Bayonne à Jean Dauger il inscrit
son premier essai en Top 14 depuis il
enchaîne les matchs avec les Espoirs et
on devrait le voir dans la liste en tout
cas il a été présélectionné pour
préparer la Coupe du Monde moins de 20
ans qui a lieu cet été au Kenya donc oui
prometteur aussi pour l'équipe de France
moins de 20 ans et peut-être pour
l'équipe de France des grands et je
parle aussi de Léo barré qui peut être
l'avenir à l'ouverture en équipe de
France bravo Nicolas un petit avis sur
cette envolée sur le sujet dont il a
parlé je suis évidemment le premier fan
de ces trois joueurs avec une petite
tendresse évidemment pour les hauts le
vert ça y est effectivement j'ai joué
avec avec son père et son grand-père
Michel était président du Rugby Club
Versailles on le suit depuis le début et
il m'attire bien c'est un joueur qui est
qui est franchement attachant c'est un
super un super garçon un super mec la
seule la seule peut-être le la seule
inquiétude ou le seul doute qui est
actuellement
son passage des U20 à France a on va
dire là ce qui va se passer dans les
prochaines années parce que bon là on le
voit en année de Coupe du monde
particulièrement il y a du monde
notamment à l'ouverture son avantage
c'est qu'il peut jouer 10 12 ou 15 il
peut jouer il peut jouer il peut couvrir
pas mal de poste chez les trois quarts
il est plutôt pressenti en 10 à
l'ouverture donc là il y a déjà romain
Tama qui est bien installé
et avec Mathieu Jalibert également au
numéro 2 donc voilà c'est peut-être
cette inquiétude là sur est-ce qu'il
aura sa chance en France a pour
poursuivre son chemin mais en tout cas
il en a le il en a le talent il en a
l'esprit il en a l'intellect et il en a
le il en a le physique et puis il est
bien entouré donc c'est tout ce qu'on
lui souhaite et bah avec l'expérience
aussi des des deux autres baies ça peut
ça peut aller juste avant Nicolas Yann
pour avoir votre avis et Philippe sur
sur cette envolée
ça montre juste que
la formation en France est possible
voilà et et en Île-de-France aussi parce
que c'était quand même un sujet qu'on
avait qu'on avait relevé il y a quelques
quelques années parce qu'on était on
était quand même un peu enfin des
avantages par des écoles qui aujourd'hui
font nos pépites sont obligés de pouvoir
partir pour continuer leur cursus
scolaire et donc du coup voilà malgré ça
on arrive quand même à sortir des à
sortir des même pas des pépites là on
est quand même sur du très très haut
niveau voilà et parce qu'une pépite ça
veut dire qu'il y a encore des il y a
encore du travail là c'est du du
confirmé et on on et et ils sont dans la
dans le très très haut niveau donc voilà
c'est c'est ça montre juste que les
lignes sont capables de sortir des des
très bons des très bons athlètes donc
ben revenons vite fait au tennis il faut
que le tennis
prenons exemple sur le rugby Philippe
moi je suis content de quand on dans le
rugby on parle des clubs formateurs ça
c'est c'est très bien je veux dire je
trouve que souvent on va parler d'un
d'un joueur qui perd son va parler de
son club formateur et ça c'est dans
d'autres sports on en parle mais moi et
je trouve que dans le rugby on en parle
ça parce que c'est pas la même moi je
compare au foot parce que voilà je suis
plus que Ruby mais ça c'est mais par
rapport à ça je trouve que c'est c'est
bien et il revienne après dans ils
viennent dans leur club souvent voir les
matchs en plus ce que comment font pas
encore à titre de comparer le foot mais
je trouve qu'il vienne en plus et ils
viennent de même ils sont même sans être
invité ils jouent le samedi ils vont
venir le dimanche dans leur club ils
vont venir mais c'est ça je trouve que
c'est c'est
la passion et je trouve que ça c'est ça
c'est top et d'en parler encore même ici
sur si on parlait sport le c'est top
Nicolas le mot de la fin peut-être pour
aller dans le sens de Philippe pour Enzo
Benegal son frère Matisse joue au
plaisir Rugby Club donc effectivement
c'est familial deuxième point c'est
concernant les hauts barré il faudra
surveiller quand même la liste la
première liste de Fabien Galtier du 15
de France pour préparer la Coupe du
monde ça sera dévoile les début juin un
groupe très élargi donc avec
potentiellement peut-être en fonction
des résultats aussi du Stade Français en
championnat peut-être une sélection de
Leo barré parce que les joueurs qui
seront éliminés des phases finales du
Top 14 seront appelés dans cette liste
et dernier point par rapport à la Coupe
du monde là aussi rugbyvinois à la fête
de villelinoise qui accueilleront des
équipes pendant la Coupe du Monde
Versailles le Pays de Galles
Croissy-sur-Seine les tons géant ça va
être exceptionnel avec les avec les
Tongiens accroît sur scène et justement
mercredi prochain le 31 mai il y a la
présentation officielle des médailles de
la Coupe du monde de rugby France 2023 à
la région
Île-de-France 153 les 153 président des
clubs franciliens sont invités avec des
petits jeunes joueurs donc là forcément
les présidents des clubs de rugby
viennois qui seront invités pour la
présentation de ces médailles et pour
les médailles j'ai rebondi sur toi c'est
que j'y serai aussi c'est parce que en
plus les médailles sont faites avec les
avec les recyclages des toutes les
médailles et ça c'est ça c'est top vous
n'êtes pas en Île-de-France Philippe on
se posait la question on se pose non
mais c'est vrai que c'est ça en plus ça
c'est un gros coup de projecteur par
rapport au développement durable ça
c'est bon
des sujets riches et des bas passionnés
malheureusement pas de place aujourd'hui
pour parler de boxe mais on aura
l'occasion de revenir sur la carrière de
Maëva à ma douche joue ré-annonce cette
information dont on parlait déjà la
dernière fois dans si on parlait sport
la fin de carrière de Maëva amadouche
qui a annoncé son retrait sur Twitter à
33 ans en raison d'une blessure à l'oeil
on aura l'occasion de revenir bien sûr
sur sa riche carrière 6 titres de
championne du monde une participation
aussi aux JO de Tokyo 2021 c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission merci d'avoir été
avec moi autour de la table on va
terminer comme d'habitude par une petite
citation et aujourd'hui je vous propose
une citation du légendaire rugbyman
Jean-Pierre arrive le rugby c'est
l'histoire de ballon avec des copains
autour et quand il n'y a plus de ballons
il reste les copains bien sûr voilà
fameuse citation de Jean-Pierre Rives
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
TV 78
[Musique]